glass houses are really important for us
here in dalford
uh it's a short summer um
and long winter we have here so
these little dwellings that we've built
all around the place
and also various frost protection
such as above here on the north side
where we can grow kiwis and citrus
and more citrus down here
yeah just it's citrus will grow well in
dalsford
uh like these lovely maya lemons
but there is a little bit of frost
protection above and so
this dwarf lumen has just um struggled
for the first
two or three years and then it's about
five or six years old now and it's
really
starting to pump same with this uh blood
orange
it's really going gangbusters now but
the first few years we had
frost protection across the top there
and it's on a north facing wall
an earth rammed earth wall and that
creates a nice heat bank
these uh citrus are doing okay here as
well
we've got more uh we've got grapefruit
lime and
mandarins over here and another orange
um again there's frost protection above
them so
it's they're not fully enclosed these
ones but they are
getting enough cross protection i've
just finished this little
cloche um the uh
the galvanized frame i got from the tip
a local glass guy cut some glass panels
for us
and the wood came from a friend's mill
liam and nick and pete's mill they're
doing awesome things out there
sustainable uh timber millers
and um all sorts of different artisans
are out there
and they're also growing food pigs and
chickens and orchards and
just awesome so yeah these were off cuts
that i was able to
repurpose um yeah so
and then there's glass houses over here
as well
again there's citrus in there we really
want to build our citrus
this one this is another blood orange
that just went in last year
it's doing really well it's like a
little tardis or
outdoor dunny this one doesn't have a
roof on it so it gets rain
but it's enough of a protection with all
the glass
in there and it really heats up
beautifully um
and uh yeah it creates a nice little
micro climate and this one
here where we're stretching a goat skin
on
at the moment but this one's growing a
jam japanese
mandarin and uh woody's got a little
pineapple
project going on over there and there's
a um we've had some
uh chili's and capsicums and then this
is a little uh
tamarillo that got knocked by the frost
so
it's in here as a nursery yeah so
basically
um glass houses greenhouses
we build them out of whatever we can old
window frames
um things that uh
we yeah we basically uh
salvage and then reconstruct and
uh put together again so
this is gardening in a cold climate
extending the growing season